I think everybody has a right to believe
that they are beautiful in their own
right because at the end of the day we
can't really do much to change our looks
and even if we do it's like a damned if
you do damned if you don't kind of
society like if we could get all
liposuction done and our face done
reconstructed but people are still going
to find something wrong right when it
came to lizzo right like I was upset
when she did do the whole like when she
like was courtside at the NBA game and
like her ass was out right not because
of her size or who she is as a person or
whatever I was more so upset because
that was not the time to do that like
right the the kids be watching
basketball too you know like this this
was inappropriate if she was doing it at
her own concert at her own Leisure we
can't say much because at the end of the
day that's what she want